hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well early on in his
essay the myth of Sisyphus Albert Camus
is going to begin using language of
effectivity and emotion he's going to
talk about the absurd as registered in
affective or emotional ways using the
terms that are translated as feeling and
passion now feeling is salty mall in
French he's also going to use the word
emotion very briefly and then passion is
just the same cognate passion so there's
this entire language of the effective
that is is running through this and
that's an important component of the
absurd it's not just a thought or a
cognition it has to do with how we feel
and our feelings at least in respect to
the world although they can be you know
off-base or wrong they are just as real
as our thoughts they're just as real a
way of engaging reality or at least what
we take to be reality as our mental
constructs so he's going to talk very
early on about this what he calls an
incalculable
necessary to life and this is in the
discussion about you know suicide he
says that a world that can be explained
even with bad reasons is a familiar
world but on the other hand in a
universe suddenly divested of illusions
and lights man feels an alien a stranger
his exile is without remedy since he's
deprived at the memory of a lost home or
the hope of a promised land and he says
this divorce between man and his life
the actor and his setting is properly
the feeling of absurdity so this is a
feeling a South amount that can arise
for us at any point in time and Camus
will give us a number of different
examples of how that might happen before
we look at that there's another
important passage where he tells us a
little bit more about feelings and how
they they play a role this is at the
beginning of the absurd walls section he
tells us that not all feelings but deep
feelings or great feelings he says
always mean more than they are conscious
of saying there's always more to any
mood any fundamental activity then that
feeling can express or that the person
feeling it can genuinely register and it
doesn't matter how much journaling you
do or how much emotional intelligence
you possess there's always going to be
this extra to it and that's something of
the very nature of emotion passion
feeling activity you know we see this is
not a radically new doctrine in the
history of philosophy you'll see Thomas
Aquinas for example saying something
quite similar about the will and how the
will and the emotions are more attached
to reality in some respects than our our
cognitions so it's it's not just
absurdist thinkers who portray feeling
in this way now Camus goes on and he
tells us some
really interesting things here he says
that great feelings take with them their
own universe
splendid or abject they light up with
their passion an exclusive world in
which they recognize their climate so a
feeling which involves a passion brings
an entire world with it we we experience
the world in part through our feelings
and there are layers or dimensions to
the world that we're really only going
to get in contact with when we feel
things certain ways he gives you
examples here he says there is a
universe of jealousy a universe of
ambition a universe of selfishness or of
generosity every person feeling these
emotions and we might say there's a
universe of rage there's a universe of
joy or bliss there's a universe of
sorrow or depression there's a universe
of anxiety
each of these brings its own not just
coloring to the world but reveals
features of the world that we otherwise
might miss absurdity will be one of
those feelings he goes on and he says
what does a universe actually mean a
universe he says included in it is in
other words a metaphysic and an attitude
of mind so what do we mean by a
metaphysic Camus is not you know delving
deep into systematic metaphysics here
he's just pointing out the fact that
every feeling commits us to a certain
kind of reality behind the appearances
think about the universe of jealousy for
example write an innocent text message
is revealed as not being what it is on
the surface in its appearances just the
text exchange but really the confession
of infidelity and love for another on
the part of say one spouse or boyfriend
or girlfriend the universe of joy takes
things that would otherwise be
rather boring and unimportant and says
there is something really wonderful here
right
that's a metaphysics and he also says an
attitude of mind the word therefore mind
is SP right so it's not just a mental
cognitive attitude it's also a sort of
general approach to things a universe
for a human being involves those it's a
way of understanding and being in the
world now he has another thing that he
says it's very interesting here in this
same section we're often not quite aware
of our own feelings right he says that
we can analyze them and we can also
analyze other people's feelings as well
so he says it's probably true that a man
remains forever unknown to us and there
is in him something irreducible that
escapes us we're all sort of our own
closed off systems as a matter of fact
we don't even completely know what's
going on in ourselves but if we observe
people over time he says practically I
know men and recognize them by their
behavior by the totality of their deeds
by the consequences cause in their in
life by their presence and he says
likewise all those irrational feelings
which offer no purchase to analysis I
can define them practically appreciate
them practically by gathering together
the sum of their consequences in the
domain of the intelligence seizing and
noting all their aspects by outlining
their universe I can understand what
feelings like joy anger sadness
frustration boredom I can understand
what these are by looking at how they
affect us practically and how that it
gives us a sort of penetration into our
own psyches and those of others we can
also do this with that of absurdity so
he says that it goes with down a little
bit further and he says there is a lower
key of feelings
inaccessible in the heart isn't that a
wonderful way to talk about it not just
that there's the conflict between the
heart and the head you know or reason in
the heart even the heart doesn't fully
understand what's going on in it and yet
those feelings are there so there's this
lower key he says of feelings
inaccessible in the heart but partially
disclosed by the acts they imply and the
attitudes of mind they assume so I might
for example come to realize that I
really am feeling anger even though I
can't let myself feel that anger
cognitively or effectively it's still
there within me right or to use caboose
focus here absurdity and he tells us in
this very same passage at any street
corner in the any street corner the
feeling of absurdity can strike any man
in the face as it is in its distressing
nudity in its light without effulgence
it is elusive but it happens to us over
and over and over again and he gives all
sorts of examples of this how we
encounter absurdity in the world I'll
just talk about a few of these he says
it happens the stage sets collapse
rising Street car for hours in the
office or the factory meal street car
for hours of work meal sleep and Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday and
Saturday according to the same rhythm
this path is easily followed most of the
time we get into these routines where
we're doing this we're doing this we
have it on our calendar we go to our
courses as we're supposed to and then he
says but one day the why arises and
everything begins and that weariness
tinged with amazement weariness comes at
the end of the acts of a mechanical life
but at the same time it inaugurates the
impulse of consciousness it awakens
consciousness and provokes what follows
and he says that this is one way that we
can have the feeling of absurdity rise
out of that lower key of feelings that
we're feeling all the time
and appear to us as something that we
now do in fact feel he gives other
examples as well you know our a relation
to time the horror that might seize us
about time perceiving that the world is
dense sensing to what degree a stone is
foreign and irreducible to us the
inhuman that we secrete as human beings
he says at certain moments of lucidity
we go on and on and on to talk about
this with examples and the examples that
he gives us are not meant to exhaust it
now what happens once we have this
experience of the absurd and the feeling
has actually arisen within us he tells
us from the moment absurdity is
recognized it becomes a passion
something that can motivate us something
that can be there driving us and he says
of this passion that it is the most
harrowing and that's how it's translated
here of all now the French is a little
bit more straightforward Dacia ron't you
know to deja la is to tear a part right
if I tear apart my let's say I'm you
know a pro-wrestler and I ripped my
shirt open rawr I'm gonna get in the
ring and beat you up it's nothing like
that I have torn my shirt apart I
haven't torn myself apart but the
feeling a passion can in fact be
something that does tear us apart think
about great rage think about great love
and infatuation think about the anguish
that you feel deciding about your future
and the future of others all those sorts
of things the absurd can become even
more harrowing harrowing in the sense of
digging a furrow into us or something
along those lines there's a it reveals
conflict within our very hearts within
our psyche so once this becomes this
harrowing passion right more than any
other he says there's a question that
arises for us he says whether or not one
can live
with one's passions whether or not one
can accept their law which is to burn
the heart they simultaneously exalt that
is the whole question now notice that
this question is being raised in an
intellectual way within the course of a
philosophical essay but in a way that we
can effectively or emotionally connect
with we can say oh yeah man I I know
what that's like
or I can at least imagine what it would
be like to have that experience the
affective dimension is incredibly
important when it comes to our encounter
with and what we respond or what we make
of the absurd for Albert Camus
you